[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et de
aidé de jean ignoble en fait vous ne
savez pas comment votre fils est mort
vous devez enquêter sur tout et vous
confronter
ils étaient ni sur la liste des morts
nés sur l'île d'eubée sexualité
hopitalisés il était nulle part parce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur et la
colère seront là jusqu'à ma mort
[Musique]
joe biden réitère son engagement
indéfectible pour la souveraineté et
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
deux jours après un sommet virtuel avec
la lumière routine le président
américain s'est entretenu hier avec
volodymyr zelensky les etats-unis
accusent depuis plus d'un mois la russie
d'avoir masse et des dizaines de
milliers de soldats près de la frontière
ukrainienne c'est dans ce contexte
électrique qu'un navire ukrainien s'est
approché des eaux russes une provocation
dénonce le kremlin
[Musique]
à la justice britannique ouvre la voie à
une extradition de julian assange vers
les elle avait refusé en première
instance refus annulés aujourd'hui par
la haute cour de justice de londres le
fondateur de wikileaks est poursuivi aux
états unis pour espionnage après avoir
publié des documents secrets de l'armée
américaine il risque jusqu'à 175 ans
présents
[Musique]
le nouveau chancelier allemand olaf
scholz était à paris ce vendredi pour
son premier déplacement officiel à
l'étranger
il a été reçu à l'elysée emmanuel macron
a salué une convergence de vues solide
en échange pour aborder les sujets du
moment internationaux et européens
à trois semaines de la présidence
française du conseil de l'ue
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur arte france
a les tensions restent vives sur le
sujet de l'ukraine voilà plusieurs
semaines maintenant que les etats-unis
et leurs alliés en europe se déclarent
inquiets face à une présumée offensive
militaire russe en préparation contre le
cren washington menace de fortes
sanctions pointant du doigt de son côté
l'expansion de l'otan moscou appelle
néanmoins au dialogue les derniers
éléments avec notre correspondante en
russie maïlys d'estrées face aux
possibles sanctions annoncées par les
états unis dans le cas où la russie
envahir l ukraine une menace que
washington kiev et leurs alliés évoquent
depuis plusieurs semaines moscou appelle
les américains à faire preuve de bon
sens et à éviter la confrontation
les réponses possibles sanctions de
notre part dans le cas du pire
développement peuvent être asymétrique
nous sommes confiants en nos forces en
la sécurité de notre défense en notre
armée
il y a des moyens de résoudre n'importe
quelle difficulté cela ne soulève pas de
questions
la question qui se pose et les
adversaires qui sont de l'autre côté
sont ils prêts à percevoir la réalité
dans toute sa profondeur et sa
signification et ne pas suivre le chemin
de plus de confrontation et de tensions
mais a passé plutôt à la recherche d
accord
d accord qui renforce réellement la
sécurité et ne servent pas de camouflage
pour la même politique dont tout le
monde est fatigué même en europe
une montée des tensions à laquelle
contribuent la menace que voilà aussi
dans un éventuel élargissement de l'otan
vers l'est et compris via l'ukraine
d'après le vice ministre russe des
affaires étrangères cet élargissement
ainsi que le déploiement de missiles à
courte et moyenne portée en europe
pourrait bien conduire à une nouvelle
crise des missiles
il faut avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
éviter une nouvelle crise des missiles
en europe l'apparition damas moyenne et
courte portée sur ces territoires est
inadmissible c'est un moyen direct
d'accroître la confrontation
afin d'éviter cela s'aggrave qu'on
appelle le temps à ne pas faire fi des
propositions russes sur la mise en place
d'un moratoire commun sur le déploiement
de forces nucléaires à portée
intermédiaire dans le cas contraire la
réponse de moscou à ce qu'elle considère
comme une menace à sa sécurité sera
différente at il mis en garde et c'est
dans ce contexte diplomatique sensible
qu'un navire de la marine ukrainienne
s'est approché ce jeudi d horus au large
de la crimée selon les services de
sécurité russes il ne disposait pas
d'autorisation
une provocation délibérée et énonce le
porte parole du kremlin les détails
arrivé à gauche man
une menace pour la sécurité de la
navigation ont estimé les services de
sécurité russes selon le fsb un hacker
de la marine ukrainienne baptisé le
donne basse s'est approché des eaux
russes au large de la crimée ce jeudi 9
décembre le navire a ignoré les appels
des gardes côtes russes à faire demi
tour alors qu'il ne disposait d'aucune
autorisation pour passer ce détroit
séparant la mer noire de la mer d'azov
pour le porte parole du kremlin dmitri
peskov il s'agit d'une provocation
délibérée d'écouté non
ce qui s'est passé mais qu'une fois de
plus le préjudice potentiel et le
dangers qui peuvent découler de telles
provocations
toute provocation peut conduire à une
aggravation de la situation c'est ce
dont parlait le président et pour la
porte parole de la diplomatie russe
marina zabbarova de tes actions de la
part des autorités ukrainiennes
s'inscrivent dans la ligne provocatrice
de l'occident aux frontières russes
écouté par moi manger sièges sur poignée
ledarnas je crois que tout le monde a
déjà tout compris d'après les
déclarations qui ont été faites par les
services de sécurité russes
je crois que c'est évident c'est encore
une provocation pas simplement un cas à
part unique individuelle mais il s'agit
d'un ensemble d'actions provocatrice qui
sont entreprises autour de nos
frontières qu'à toi le seul est ce votre
look match granit dans un communiqué
publié sur facebook les forces du miso
kényanes ont dénoncé les fausses
déclarations du fsb assurant que le
navire avait manoeuvré dans les eaux de
créer une hyène sans se rendre dans les
zones sensibles et qu'elle rentrait
ensuite à sa base sans faire mention des
communications avec les gardes côtes
russes dont faisait état moscou
l'incident survient alors que les
tensions entre d'une part le cren et ses
alliés occidentaux y compris les états
unis et de l'autre par la russie sont
vives le 9 décembre déjà des avions
militaires français et américains ont
été escortés par des chasseurs russes au
dessus de la mer noire ce type
d'incident se sont multipliés ces
derniers jours et on décrypte ces
tensions autour de la question d'ukraine
avec nos deux invités chez nicolas à
mercredi china liste politique et gérard
ollivier journaliste franco américain
chercheur à l'ehess
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france on secoue
ironisé sur le fait que cela fait
longtemps maintenant que la russie est
soupçonné d'être sur le point d'envahir
l'ukraine est ce qu'il est pertinent de
se demander à qui profite cette crise
qui dure gérard ollivier
lancé gérald avec un avec un job et on
pense qu'il faut il faut raison garder
dans ce dans ce contexte parce que les
états unis et la russie sont toujours
des adversaires mais l'enjeu n'est plus
existentielles ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre nous ne sommes plus au temps de
la guerre froide ou non seulement deux
pays mais de système et deux idéologies
s'opposaient et la victoire de l'as
impliquait la disparition de l'autre
aujourd'hui les états unis n'ont plus
d'autre intérêt vital en ukraine que le
fait que ce pays puisse jouir de sa
souveraineté nationale et que son
intégrité territoriale soient respectés
ça ne va pas au delà alors la question
de la sécurité de l'ukraine évidemment
pose problème parce que d'un côté le
cren voudrait bien le parapluie de
l'otan ce qu'il assurerait de ne jamais
rien craindre ou de son voisin quand
même beaucoup plus puissant que la
russie et de l'autre l'un des meilleurs
poutine la russie considère qu'une
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'otan serait
une ligne rouge qui appliquerait une
réponse semble être de nature militaire
donc je pense que malheureusement il
faut soutenir l'attention et attendre
que les choses je dirais retombe un
petit peu et envisager plutôt une
solution quelques celles qui concernent
aussi bien la finlande ou la suède qui
sont des pays voisins de la russie et
qui ne sont pas nécessairement membre de
l'otan et qu'il ne se sent pas néanmoins
menacée par la russie donc
l'indépendance de l'ukraine est quand
même un épisode qui reste tout à fait
récent remonte à une trentaine d'années
les choses ne sont pas apaisées c'est un
pays qui possède une importante
population russe et qui doit respecter à
la fois l'héritage et de la culture de
cette population je pense que la
situation est très différente de celle
que l'avion avec la crimée parce que
l'histoire de ces deux pays n'est pas la
même y compris l'histoire récente est
donc pour l'instant c'est juste une
montée de tension qui à mon avis reste
une crise diplomatique dont l' issue
diplomatique demeure plus que probable
quelle est la situation en termes de
politique intérieure justement en
ukraine nicolas mirkovic le président
ukrainien est au pouvoir depuis deux ans
maintenant il avait été élu on s'en
souvient sur sa promesse à la fois de
lutter contre la corruption sur la
promesse aussi de faire la paix dans le
donbass l'est de l'ukraine où un conflit
oppose des séparatistes au gouvernement
de kiev vladimir poutine à d'ailleurs
estimé dans la journée et que la
situation rappeler un génocide il a
évoqué la russophobie dont sont victimes
les populations locales est ce qu'on
peut faire un lien entre la gestion du
pouvoir du président ukrainien volodimir
zelensky ce focus qu'il fait sur moscou
malheureusement oui pour regarder les
résultats de zain qui depuis qu'il est
au pouvoir il avait promis de ramener la
paix au donbass il avait promis de
lutter contre la corruption il avait
promis de d'éviter que des milliers
centaines de milliers d'ukrainiens fui
et qui reste en ukraine pour on pourra
retrouver du travail aujourd'hui le
résultat les piètres il est très mauvais
le taux d'inflation aujourd'hui en
ukraine est intense pour cent les
investissements directs étrangers sont
négatives c'est à dire que les capitaux
qui sont arrivés en ukraine puis
l'ukraine aujourd'hui on part de bruits
de bottes sur la frontière ya une
tension réelle au donbass et le bilan 2
hélène ce qui est très beau mais
n'oublions pas que washington est un des
premiers états qui dénoncent aujourd'hui
donc c'est un des plus grands alliés de
l'ukraine dénonce aujourd'hui la
corruption rampante aujourd'hui malgré
la présence de leur chouchou zelensky au
pouvoir donc je dîne ce qui n'arrive pas
à mettre en place son programme c'est un
échec là la
corruption continue il ya toujours des
menaces de guerre en ukraine et on a
l'impression que la seule chose
zielinski peut trouver pour essayer de
rassembler des ukrainiens ont essayé de
le faire bien voir justement par
washington et bien c'est de maintenir un
foyer de tension sur la frontière russe
on sait que les faucons de guerre de
l'otan aime beaucoup ce foyer de tension
il ya énormément d'activités des navi
des avions de l'otan des navires de
l'otan sur la frontière russo des
exercices ces dernières années avec plus
de trente mille soldats de lente de
l'otan dans des pays limitrophes de la
dola de la russie dans l'otan cherche la
provocation je pense qu'ils aimeraient
bien que la russie perde son sang-froid
et tombe dans le piège que la russie ne
fait pas pour l'instant la seule façon
que trouve zelensky pour essayer de
sortir de cette situation on va dire
politiquement mauvaise sa cote de
popularité est au plus bas eh bien ces
deux d'attiser un peu là la fibre
patriotique en dénonçant moscou comme si
moscou était responsable de tous ces
maux alors que le seul responsable des
monts ukraine aujourd'hui bien il faut
le dire c'est zelensky qui a mis la
situation pays dans cette situation vous
êtes d'accord gérald olivier avec cette
idée selon laquelle il ya un contexte
intérieur un terreau favorable dont
profitent des acteurs extérieurs à la
région comme les états unis et puis
l'otan aussi
je pense que les deux leaders jouent
exactement la même cas
parce que bon je ne crois pas aux
provocations de l'otan ce n'est pas du
tout l'intérêt de l'otan de provoquer
une intervention russe aujourd'hui en
ukraine dans la mesure où il n'y a rien
il n'y a aucun accord de sécurité qui
obligerait l'otan à intervenir en
ukraine donc la situation serait
catastrophique si c'était le cas non je
pense que les deux leaders jouent sur la
veine populiste et vladimir poutine
aussi la demir poutine aime bien
présente et l'occident les etats-unis
l'europe comme des puissances qui sont
toujours hostile à la russie à la russie
historique à la russie d'aujourd'hui
il aime bien jouer sur la veine
nationaliste et on sait très bien qu'il
y a des nationalistes russes en ukraine
donc il a une excuse pour le faire mais
dans cette situation faut pas se tromper
d'agresseurs c'est à dire que le cren
veut c'est le petit dans l'histoire et
l'otan n'a pas de lien de sécurité
aujourd'hui des accords de sécurité avec
l'ukraine ça fait 30 ans que l'ukraine
demande à rentrer dans l'otan ils ne
sont pas encore membres de ce qu'on
appelle le plan d'action est pour
l'instant il n'y a sur la table des
négociations et l'otan aucunement une
candidature de l'ukraine considéré
demain sérieuse n'a été faite
gérald olivier on apprend à l'instant
l'otan rejette le veto de moscou sur une
éventuelle adhésion de l'ukraine la
dépêche de l'agencé france presse vient
tout juste de tomber nicolas sociaux oui
votre regard de l'allée des justes pour
terminer par rapport à ces dépêches ou
c'est parfaitement normal parce que les
règles des règles de l'otan disent qu'il
n'appartient pas à un pays extérieurs à
l'otan de dictée qui peut remplir une
parente rick donc il était parfaitement
logique que le temps fasse ce genre de
de communiquer maintenant encore une
fois je pense que les deux leaders
jouent sur une certaine veine
nationaliste connaît une poussée de
tension que les troupes les troupes
russes sont bien là et que dans le cas
d'un conflit entre l'ukraine et la
russie la question de savoir qui serait
le vainqueur laisse assez peu de doute
donc il n'est pas du tout dans l'intérêt
l'ukrainien de pousser trop loin la
provocation nicolas sarkozy dise comment
est ce que vous vous accueillez cette
annonce de l'otan est ce que vous vous
diriez que l'otan profite d'un contexte
pour encourager kiev quelles sont ses
intentions selon vous oui je joue je
pense au contraire que l'otan profite
l'otan cherchent à provoquer et si le
temps en effet n'a pas d'accord avec le
créneau aujourd'hui il faut pas oublier
que ce sont quand même des pays membres
de l'otan qui sont en train d'inspecter
les troupes du craignait sur la ligne de
front dont basse c'est sont les états
unis qui ont débloqué un budget de 500
millions de dollars d'être militaire à
l'ukraine ce sont des entraîneurs
américains et malheureusement aussi
d'autres pays de l'otan qui sont en
ukraine pour former les soldats
ukrainiens de signer cette hypocrisie de
dire que l'otan le ne s'impliquerait pas
dans l'un des problèmes de l'ukraine
paiera pas d'accord et en même temps
d'envoyer des soldats de l'otan forme et
armés là le soleil crinière donc du coup
bien sûr que le temps que ça parce qu'au
sein même de l'otan il y a beaucoup de
personnes dans la hiérarchie qui pensent
qu'ils ne savent pas que la guerre
froide est terminée et qu'ils veulent à
tout prix cette situation de tension en
effet je pense la russie n'a aucun
intérêt à voir une guerre aucun intérêt
du tout la russie veut développer les
commerces la russie a développé avec le
nord de l'ouest et de nombreuses
sociétés européennes
'pipeline' nord stream 2 qui devrait
être lancée c'est l'intérêt de l'est de
la russie qui veulent faire tomber les
censier les sanctions imposées et
sanctions économiques imposées par des
pays de l'otan ont du coup c'est pas la
russie qui alla la russie est plutôt de
la victime dans cette histoire parce que
du coup ce sont les pays membres de
l'otan qui n'arrêtent pas d'imposer des
sanctions qui vont faire des patrouilles
militaires sur la frontière sur les
frontières russes et qui essayait
d'attiser cette situation dont l'as
n'oublions pas que si les pays membres
de l'otan voulait la paix deux pays
membre de l'otan la france et
l'allemagne sont co signataire des
accords de minsk 2 qui vise la paix au
donbass ces accords de paix 2010 que 2
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'entend jamais la
france et l'allemagne n'en parlait où
sont les responsables politiques
français et allemands qui en ukraine
pour rappeler les obligations à
l'ukraine ses obligations de paix
pourquoi est ce que c'est les différents
éléments de cet accord des ministres ne
sont pas mises en place et pourquoi est
ce que les pays membres de l'otan ne met
pas la pression sur l'ukraine pour
qu'elles respectent ces accords au lieu
d'envoyer des soldats des troupes des
armes les pays membres de l'otan
notamment tout cas la france elle même
serait mieux d'utiliser leur force
diplomatique
et leurs moyens pour rappeler à kiev ces
obligations pour trouver une solution
pacifique dans le donbass quelles sont
les intentions réelles des états unis
dans cette escalade des tensions gérald
olivier washington qui effectivement
remet dans le jeu le gazoduc north
stream ii entre la russie l'allemagne et
l'utilisent comme levier comme moyen de
pression vis-à-vis de moscou
justement non les états unis ne
l'utilisent pas comme moyen de pression
parce que les sanctions auxquelles mon
collègue faisait allusion il ya quelques
minutes elles sont été levée par
l'administration by d'inde alors certes
à l'heure actuelle seul ce gazoduc north
stream 2 il n'est pas en opération
d'accord mais le l'obstacle qui avait
été mise en place par le congrès
américain sous forme de saab sion de
grâce contre gazprom ces sanctions ont
été levées au printemps et les états
unis ont donné un feu vert principe à ce
que ce cet oléoduc entre en activité ce
qui d'ailleurs est relativement
incohérent parce que une fois que 7e du
fonctionnement et bien l'ukraine sera
privé d'un certain nombre revenu à
travers les droits de transit du gaz qui
passe par les pipelines qui traversent
son propre territoire donc là les états
unis ont tiré un petit peu dans le quai
de leurs alliés si l'ukraine est
véritablement leurs alliés dans la
situation parce qu'ils vont leur priver
de revenus qui sont relativement
importants mais ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que aujourd'hui le cren n'est pas
un intérêt stratégique vital des états
unis aujourd'hui l'intérêt stratégique
vital des états unis il se situe sur le
terrain de l'inde au pacifique et se
situe vis-à-vis de la chine la menace
existentielle pour la chine 21e siècle
ce n'est plus la russie de vladimir
poutine s'est lassé lashing de chip jean
ping est ce que la politique américaine
au cours des 15 dernières années
consiste justement à se désengager d'un
certain nombre de théâtres et ça c'est
une politique qui marque une certaine
continuité d'une administration
démocrate à une administration
républicaine à une autre administration
démocrate se désengager d'un certain
nombre de théâtre y compris
l'afghanistan tenue dernièrement pour
justement avoir les mains libres et
pouvoir se concentrer sur ce qui pour
eux est la menace principale qui est
celle qui oppose la chine communiste en
termes démographiques en termes
économiques en termes technologiques et
en termes militaires vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble de la région de la blinde
opacifie donc les états unis n'ont aucun
intérêt à ce qu'il y ait un conflit
autour du donbass en ukraine et ils
n'ont aucune intention de s'engager au
delà de la fourniture d'armes et d'un
appui je dirais diplomatique dans un
conflit potentiel et je vous laisse
répondre nicolas mercat vais te laissera
le mot de la fin je pense que je m'en
allais fait l'ennemi principal des états
unis c'est clairement la chine pour
autant les etats-unis ne se désengage
pas de cette région n'oublions pas que
ce sont quand même les états unis qui
sont derrière les révolutions de l'euro
maidan victoria nuland qui a encore dans
l'administration baidal aujourd'hui à
l'époque avait avoué les états unis
avaient dépensé de l'argent pour
apporter la démocratie en ukraine et que
c'est suite à cette révolution de
couleur et du changement brutal de
gouvernement inquiète que nous avons
eues à ces tensions en ukraine qui sont
exacerbées et qui ont mené à la guerre
civile c'est quand même moi shrimpton
qui est derrière tout appelé leurs
médailles vous avez le patron de la cia
qui débarque le patron de la cia qui
débarque en ukraine si les étés depuis
ce temps là on voit très bien les la
main de washington dans l'organisation
de l'administration
à kiev quel que soit le président que ce
soit pour chez nous aujourd'hui zelensky
je pense que peut-être que les états
unis dans une vision plus longue est ce
le grand échiquier vont monnayer le cren
avec la russie c'est possible pour
autant les américains l'otan en tout cas
les américains le gouvernement abandonne
aujourd'hui les soldats de l'otan sont
bien présents autour de la zone du
donbass ils sont présents en mer noire
les avions de l'otan patrouillent le
long des frontières russes clairement
pour essayer de mettre la pression sur
la russie peut-être pourra-t-on monnayer
en tout cas ça plaisait ça peut ça peut
l'espérer d on ne sait jamais ce qui
peut arriver il ya encore quelques jours
à l'avion de ligne avec des civils
russes a failli percuter un avion espion
allemande à payer de l'otan un incident
comme ça peut déclencher une guerre et
son label entre différentes puissances
nucléaires je pense que c'est quelque
chose d'extraordinaire et que washington
ferait mieux de faire très attention
parce que du coup ça il ya un brasier
potentiel dans cette région là s'il
était sincère il quitterait l'endroit et
laissera la diplomatie il laisserait la
diplomatie et la place et retirerait les
troupes parce que c'est diplomatiquement
qui doivent régler le problème est
beaucoup
merci nicolas mirkovic analystes
politiques merci à vous également gérald
ollivier journaliste franco américain
chercheurs ali ps
julian assange pourrait finalement être
extradé vers les états unis la justice
britannique a annulé ce vendredi en
appel une précédente décision qui avait
refusé en janvier l'extradition du
fondateur de wikileaks
cette demande pourrait donc être
réexaminé julian assange risque 175 ans
de prison pour avoir publié des
documents secrets de l'armée américaine
les précisions de bilal loisonnais
le combat est loin d'être terminé pour
julian assange alors que l'on célèbre
aujourd'hui la journée internationale
des droits de l'homme la justice
britannique a annulé le refus
d'extradition du journaliste vers les
états unis prononcée en janvier ouvrant
ainsi la porte à un possible procès sur
le sol américain la haute cour a estimé
que les états unis avaient fourni les
assurances nécessaires concernant le
traitement de julian assange en cas
d'extradition une grave erreur
judiciaire
aux yeux de stella maurice avocate et
fiancée de julian assange
comment ces tribunaux peuvent-ils
approuvé une demande d'extradition dans
ces conditions comment peuvent-ils
accepter une extradition vers le pays
qui a comploté pour tuer julian qui a
comploté pour tuer un éditeur à cause de
ceux qu'il a publiés
nous allons continuer le combat chaque
génération a un combat épique à mener
est celui ci est le nôtre parce que
julian représentent les fondements de ce
que cela signifie de vivre dans une
société libre de ce que cela signifie
d'avoir la liberté de la presse de ce
que cela signifie pour les journalistes
de faire leur travail sans avoir peur de
passer le reste de leur vie en prison
profondément inquiète plusieurs ong dont
amnesty international et reporters sans
frontières ont demandé mi-octobre dans
une lettre ouverte au ministre américain
de la justice d'abandonner les
poursuites au nom de la liberté de la
presse défendue par le gouvernement
américain en vain
ce sont des paroles absolument vide
comme celles proférées par le
gouvernement byden qui persiste à
poursuivre julian assange donc cela n'a
aucun sens vous ne pouvez pas déclaré
que vous luttez pour la démocratie la
liberté d'expression et que vous
acceptez l'importance du journalisme
dans le processus démocratique tout en
essayant de faire en sorte que tu
viennes assange soit condamné à une
peine de prison de 175 ans c'est
impossible
derrière les barreaux de la prison
londonienne de haute sécurité où il est
incarcéré l'australien peut compter sur
de nombreux soutiens ses supporters se
sont réunis devant le tribunal pour
protester contre cette décision
le combat continue devant la justice
dans les rues et partout ailleurs pour
libérer julian assange et lutter pour ce
qui est juste il ne mérite pas ce
traitement c'est une poursuite
incessante depuis dix ans et elle doit
s'arrêter
j'espère que le système judiciaire
reviendra sur cette décision sans
fondement ils retiennent quelqu'un qui
n'est reconnu d'aucun crime incarcéré
alors que la procédure est en cours
de son côté la russie a également
dénoncé la décision de la justice
britannique
la cour d'appel d'angleterre et du pays
de galles a autorisé l'extradition
d'assange vers les états unis ce verdict
honteux dans le cadre d'une affaire
politique contre un journaliste et homme
public est une autre manifestation de la
vision cannibale du monde qu'est le
tandem anglo saxons c'est d'une manière
digne que l'occident a célébré la
journée internationale des droits de
l'homme et la fin du sommet pour la
démocratie
poursuivi notamment dans le cadre d'une
loi américaine sur l'espionnage assange
s'il est extradé vers les états unis est
reconnu coupable risque jusqu'à 175 ans
de prison
comme le veut la tradition c'est à la
france coloniale a réservé son premier
déplacement officiel à l'étranger
le nouveau chancelier allemand
successeur dans gala merkel a été reçu à
l'elysée par emmanuel macron un échange
de vues dont s'est réjoui le chef de
l'état évoquant une convergence le récit
de ciel bleu et
une première visite officielle sous le
signe de l'amitié franco allemande deux
jours après sa prestation de serment le
nouveau chancelier allemand olaf scholz
s'est rendu à paris pour un entretien en
tête à tête et un déjeuner avec emmanuel
macron une rencontre amicale dont s'est
félicité le président français je crois
que ces premiers échanges traduisent
très clairement une convergence de vues
solide tout cas j'étais très heureux
chez relève de te recevoir
à paris aujourd'hui pour ce premier
déplacement
hors d'allemagne avant que tu ne
rejoigne bruxelles et j'ai pu voir des
convictions solides sur beaucoup de ces
sujets une convergence de vues une
volonté de
faire travailler ensemble nos deux pays
et une conviction européenne que je
connaissais déjà
ferme déterminée et dont nous aurons
besoin dans les mois et années à venir
au programme de cette rencontre
relations avec la chine
question migratoire ou encore crise en
ukraine les deux hommes ont avant tout
mis en avant leur projet commun l'union
européenne ce qui est arrivé en europe
nous voulons renforcer l'europe
travaillait la souveraineté européenne
dans toutes les dimensions qui s'y
rapportent les questions économiques de
sécurité ou encore de politique
étrangère nous devons agir ensemble
travailler étroitement ensemble ce
n'était donc pas seulement une rencontre
amicale mais une conversation très
concrètes sur toutes les thématiques qui
seront à l'ordre du jour les prochaines
semaines
une étape fructueuse donc pour le
nouveau chancelier qui entame son
premier voyage officiel olaf scholz
poursuit sa tournée en belgique afin de
rencontrer le secrétaire général de
l'otan et c'est la fin de ce journal on
se retrouve dans une trentaine de
minutes pour un nouveau journal à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
le long chemin de la réconciliation
nationale depuis deux décennies en côte
d'ivoire au moins le processus est il
sur le point de se concrétiser le
blocage véritable se situe au niveau des
hommes politiques plus de 3000 ivoiriens
en perdront la vie lors de la crise post
électorale de 2010 2011 y avait beaucoup
de tension ça tire de partout c'était
des formats l'as cozes et canton soit et
envoyait des tasses des balles par ci
par là envoyer des cadavres en moins
d'une semaine c'était c'était le chaos
après 2010 il y avait deux camps celui
des vainqueurs et des vaincus est-ce que
la situation s'est quand même amélioré à
ce niveau le châtel que la victime se
plaignent tous jouent le fait est que
sur le terrain les divisions existent ou
jouent le jeu fait est que le climat
politique n'est pas encore véritablement
apaisé
[Musique]
un
des freins à priori du nucléaire c'est
l'émergence dé nouvelles sources
d'énergie aujourd'hui nous sommes le
pays qui produit l'électricité la plus
décarbonés au monde on peut rêver à
couvrir toute la planète de des
éoliennes mais quand ça produit un tiers
du temps que fait-on pour le res d'appui
il ya aussi la démographie en sont
toujours à l'afrique quand même avec un
milliard d'habitants plus la surface de
l'afrique ne sera pas suffisante pour
mettre des panneaux solaires ou sinon ça
se fera